Plymouth Massachusetts is in a festive
mood as Thanksgiving is just around the
corner we see the local sheriff Eric
nulan visiting his friend Mitch
Collins's house to celebrate the
occasion inside he meets with Mitch's
wife Amanda and the two greet each other
rather affectionately the group then
gathers for dinner and everyone appears
to be in a happy mood but just before
the feast can begin Mitch reveals that
his boss has summoned him to work right
now turns out he is the manager at w
Mart the largest and the most popular
supermarket in town tonight the Black
Friday sale begins and a huge number of
people are expected to show up and
probably trample and punch each other
trying to get a Nintendo switch
following this we are taken to the house
of Thomas Wright the owner of the W Mar
stores a massive Feast is underway and a
lot of people are in attendance but the
environment doesn't seem joyous at all
this is because Thomas's teenage
daughter Jessica doesn't like her
stepmom Kathleen Jessica's boyfriend and
popular baseball player Bobby is also
present in the room but he doesn't have
much of an opinion on the matter because
he's a high school athlete and thus dumb
as a brick after the awkward dinner ends
the teenagers are picked up by their
friends Evan Gabby scuba and ulia they
have planned to watch a horror movie and
they seem pretty excited about it along
the way they trash talk about their
rival School hover and Evan is the one
making the most insults he is revealed
to be in a relationship with Gabby while
scuba and ulia have just started dating
scuba enjoys plugging his nose and going
down in the next scene the group is
stuck in traffic as the streets are
filled with people lining up for the
Black Friday sales this tempts the
driver Evan and he too decides to make a
quick stop at the store he reasons that
his phone has been damaged so he wants
to get a new one the teenagers then get
easy access through the back door oh as
Jessica's dad is the owner of the place
while on their way Jessica bumps into
one of her classmates Ryan who has a
massive crush on her he attempts to
initiate a conversation but Bobby
intervenes and takes her away you just
struck out says Bobby outside at the
gates the crowd has reached dangerous
levels they are growing unruly and
impatient with each passing second to
make matters worse one of the Handover
kids Lonnie spots our protagonists
inside the store this infuriates him and
he provokes the others about the
Injustice sheriff nulan and Amanda have
also arrived at the store to do some
shopping but they are completely unaware
of what's happened outside just then the
barrier guarding the crowd breaks and
thousands of people run towards the
store this causes a stampede as the main
gate is still locked Mitch and his
colleagues look on in horror as several
people are crushed against the glass
wall before they can do something about
it the glass shatters causing absolute
Carnage in the store as the people Rush
inside one of the guards is trampled to
death while a customer has his neck
slashed the hell what is this people are
now fighting against each other for the
discounted goods and many of them even
resort to violence seeing this the
teenagers are terrified and they quickly
rush to a safe location but Evan sees
this as the perfect opportunity to be
famous so he climbs on a table and
starts recording the whole thing on his
phone world star yeah as the Carnage
continues Bobby attempts to help an
injured man but his hand is crushed in
the process we are then shown Amanda who
is crawling through the floors
Desperately Seeking an exit route
unfortunately before she can get to
safety her head is slammed by someone's
shopping cart this causes her to die
instantly the situation is finally
brought under control when the sheriff
fires a shot in the air the scene then
cuts to one year after the incident it
is thanksgiving's Eve and R Mar is once
again gearing up for its Black Friday
sales despite what happened the last
time don't these people know about
Amazon people are vehemently protesting
this and Mitch is the one leading them a
news report states that the Court ruled
the entire thing in accident so that the
right family didn't have to face any
trouble Bobby suffered a career-ending
injury and he has distanced himself from
everyone since then he may only have two
balls but he feels like he's been walked
the only one who benefited from the
incident is Evan as his video has gained
millions of views online the next
morning sheriff nulan and his Deputy are
chatting at a local Diner when the
waitress Lizzy hands them a mask it is
of John Carver the first mayor of New
Plymouth Colony the sheriff mentions
that he is very popular in this town so
all the residents will be wearing his
mask this Thanksgiving as the festival
nears a local fair is organized in the
nearby Market Evan who is a bit
competitive by nature is participating
in an axe throwing competition meanwhile
the girls are talking about a mysterious
Instagram user who uploads videos of the
Stampede and keeps tagging them while
everyone is engrossed in the activities
someone enters the John Carver House and
vandalizes it turns out rart was
supposed to film an ad campaign there
but now now the place is completely
messed up after a while Sheriff nulan
arrives at the scene and Promises to
find the culprit in the next scene we
see the teenagers having lunch at a
diner while they chat Jessica suddenly
spots Bobby which means that he has
returned to the town this makes her
emotional but she chooses to forget
about him right then an Instagram user
by the name of John Carver uploads a
creepy post which includes a table ready
for Thanksgiving dinner he tags all of
the teenagers as usual but doesn't give
much context disregarding this the group
continues with their chitchat Jessica
reveals that she has started dating Ryan
as he has always cared for her the
others find him a bit Shady but Ryan
suddenly shows up and impresses them by
handing them some match tickets back at
the diner we see Lizzy preparing to head
home it is revealed that she is the same
woman who accidentally killed Amanda on
that fateful night as she approaches the
door suddenly a guy wearing a John
Carver mask attacks her he beats her up
before sticking her face into the the
Frozen refrigerator door the killer then
goes to retrieve his axe intending to
kill her Lizzie somehow manages to free
herself by painfully tearing off her
flesh she rushes out of the back door
and attempts to get into her car but
finds that it has been locked terrified
she tries to hide in a dumpster but the
killer slams her with her own car
splitting her in half how's that for 50%
off discount when the Sun rises a large
crowd gathers outside the W Mart store
where lizz's lower half bought is
hanging simultaneously the teenagers are
tagged in a new Instagram post which
depicts the same mutilated body Jessica
then checks the previous post and
discovers that all of their names are
written on the dinner table terrified
she immediately calls her dad explaining
that they are in danger however Thomas
Wright isn't going to be intimidated so
easily he tells his daughter that the
Black Friday sales will go ahead as
planned meanwhile with pressure mounting
on the officers Sheriff nulan finally
begins an investigation into the case he
checks the CCTV footage at the diner and
is shocked to find the killer wearing a
John Carver mask without wasting any
time he calls the teenagers to his
office and inquires if they know anyone
who would want to hurt them however all
of them answer in the negative later
Jessica runs into Bobby who is back in
town to help his uncle since the two
haven't met in almost a year they start
off awkwardly but soon start talking his
friends Bobby explains that he spiraled
into depression after his baseball
career ending he wanted to be alone just
hang out in the outfield for a while and
that's why he ghosted all his friends
Jessica promptly forgives him and says
that she has something to share as well
she reveals that her stepmother Kathleen
deleted the security footage from that
fateful night fearing that they would
face lawsuits but they still have a
backup in her dad's office and she's
planning to retrieve it as the two
continue talking Ryan suddenly arrives
and gives Jessica a kiss on her cheeks
cheeks this obviously makes Bobby a bit
jealous and he wants to call foul but he
manages to control his emotions the
scene then cuts to Manny one of the
security guards from the Stampede Knight
it is revealed that he fled the scene
instead of opening the gates even this
time he is planning to run away to
another country as he fears his life is
in danger unfortunately just when he is
about to depart the killer Dawning the
John Carver mask shows up Manny senses
his presence and grabs a bat to defend
himself but it is useless the killer
impales him from behind and brutally
decapitates him at night he places the
head on the dinner table along with
lizz's upper half body and posts it on
his Instagram account why hasn't forchan
figured out where this guy lives yet
when Jessica finds herself tagged in the
post the next morning she is terrified
realizing that the Killer is closing in
on her she hastily gets the security
footage from her dad's computer and
hands it over to the sheriff on the
other hand we see Lonnie the same
Handover kid who instigated the Stampede
he seemed seems to have moved on from
the incident and is currently working as
a gym instructor a while later he and
his girlfriend go to a secluded room to
fool around she gets on a trampoline and
starts to strip while Lonnie watches her
intently if she starts bouncing I'm
going to explode just then the killer
approaches him from behind and snaps his
neck the girl is unaware of this and she
keeps on jumping but the killer finishes
her off as well by stabbing her multiple
times from beneath the trampoline in the
next scene we learned that the football
game between the two rival schools has
been cancelled due to the mysterious
deaths Sheriff Nan tells the teenagers
to go home as soon as possible Evan and
Gabby then head to their classes to
retrieve their stuff while Jessica waits
for them outside this is when the killer
shows up once again he finds the two
kids alone and knocks them out he then
uses Gabby's phone to lure Jessica
inside but before he can kill her she
manages to run away upon reaching
outside she pleads with Sheriff Newan to
save her friends however even after an
extensive search neither the killer nor
the teenagers are found realizing that
the cops are useless scuba decides to
get a gun for himself he goes to a local
drug dealer's house along with Jessica
and rents a pistol on the other hand
ulia and her dad have decided to leave
town as they fear the Killer is coming
for them they are currently packing
their stuff while a guard is stationed
outside as expected the killer shows up
and incapacitates the security guard he
then shoots ulia's father dead before
going after her unaware of what's
Happening downstairs ulia is on a video
call with her boyfriend scuba the latter
is currently on his way to drop Jessica
off at home just then the killer shows
up and stabs Julia's ears with sharp
pins as she screams in agony he grabs
her phone and waves at scuba the
boyfriend and Jessica quickly arrive to
save her but the killer has her at knife
point in front of their eyes he throws
ulia on a buzz saw shredding her to
pieces he then manages to get away
through the window in the aftermath of
these events the cops decide to
implement a daring strategy they intend
to draw out the perpetrator during the
Thanksgiving Parade by employing Jessica
and her family as bait Kathleen is
hesitant about this but Thomas and
Jessica convince her to participate
saying this is the only way to catch the
killer unfortunately at the parade the
killer once again manages to outsmart
them instead of wearing his classic John
Carver mask he shows up in a clown
costume much less conspicuous he gets to
work by decapitating a mascot and
throwing smoke bombs everywhere this
causes absolute chaos and the police are
unable to get to him the killer then
Corners Jessica and her family in a car
tranquilizes them and drives them away
when Kathleen wakes up that night she
finds the killer preparing her like a
turkey she momentarily manages to run
away but he catches up to her and cooks
her in the oven giving her a painful
death the GTA game over screen pop pops
up but it says basted in the next scene
Kathleen's roasted body is brought to
the dinner table horrifying everyone the
guests are Jessica Thomas scuba Evan and
Gabby they are all tied up to their
respective chairs the killer then takes
the dinner to the next level by going
live on Instagram and smashing Evan's
head with a hammer he then turns his
attention to Thomas and tries to feed
him Kathleen's meat during this Jessica
somehow manages to free herself using
her Secret Ring she hands it over to
scuba granting him Freedom as well the
two then attack the Killer and make a
run for it after a while of running
scuba tries to take on the killer
himself he gets injured in the process
but he does manage to buy Jessica enough
time to escape she dashes through the
dark woods before eventually arriving at
the Town Center there she is greeted by
a grim sight sheriff nulan is lying
unconscious on the ground just then she
sees someone entering the nearby
Warehouse thinking that it is the killer
Jessica grabs the Sheriff's gun and goes
after him but to her shock she discovers
that he is none other than her ex Bobby
that was so obvious but I didn't want to
say anything just then the sheriff comes
running to her and asks her to get out
he then Fires at Bobby but the latter
manages to get away later on some more
cops arrive at the scene and inform
Jessica that her friends and Dad have
been rescued Sheriff nulan then has a
private conversation with her where he
promises to find Bobby but at this point
Jessica discovers something shocking the
sheriff has brambles on his shoes the
same ones she saw in the forest earlier
this proves that the John Carver killer
is none other than nulan himself oh okay
when she confronts him about it he
finally decides to explain the entire
truth years ago when his wife passed
away he fell into depression and almost
committed the unthinkable but that was
when he met Mitch's wife Amanda and they
immediately hit it off she brought
happiness into his life and gradually
helped him recover she even got pregnant
with his child and was planning to
divorce Mitch however their romantic
story came to an end when she was killed
at w Mar ever since that day nulan has
planned to take revenge against all
those who were responsible for Amanda's
demise he was actually planning to frame
Bobby for all the deaths but the boy
managed to knock him out before running
away as the sheriff continues with his
confession Jessica is live streaming
everything from her phone when he finds
out about it he tries to kill her with
his classic axe but Bobby arrives just
in time and saves her he would have
gotten away with it too if it hadn't
been for scuba Doo and all those medling
kids the two then run inside the
warehouse where Jessica turns on a gas
cylinder it starts inflating a large
balloon which is combustible when the
killer approaches them she uses a
makeshift gun and shoots at the balloon
this causes an explosion so big that the
sheriff is thrown away seemingly killing
him him in the aftermath of the incident
the cops search every nook and corner of
the warehouse but they aren't able to
find the sheriff thus they assume that
he was totally reduced to ashes however
when Jessica notices a masked
firefighter coming out of the warehouse
she thinks it is him that night as she
is sleeping with Ryan she is a nightmare
where the killer suddenly attacks her
from behind this brings the movie to an
end leaving us to ponder if the sheriff
is still alive and if we'll get a cheap
sequel subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching